good evening I'm Bret Baier we're coming
to you live tonight from the White House
tonight new questions about what the
Trump administration did or did not do
about domestic abuse allegations against
former staff secretary Rob Porter the
director of the FBI today seemed to
dispute the White House timeline about
whether the security clearance procedure
was finished or ongoing when Porter quit
his job last week and we have learned
Porter was being considered for a
promotion right up until his resignation
chief White House correspondent John
Roberts here on the North Lawn with all
of this a big storage on yeah it
continues to be it now we're almost into
day seven here is something that the lot
of people think the White House should
have been able to put away in the first
couple of days sources tell Fox News
that the White House was considering
expanding the staff secretary Rob
Porter's role to possibly include some
of the duties of the deputy chief of
staff Jim Carroll who was nominated last
week by the President to be the drug
czar the week before that actually the
White House continues to insist that the
worst of the revelations about Porter
were not known until very recently
propping a competing narrative today
from the FBI a day after the White House
suggested the FBI clearance process
failed to illuminate the allegations
against Rob Porter in a timely fashion
FBI director Christopher ray tried to
throw the White House under the bus the
FBI submitted a partial report on the
investigation in question in March and
then a completed background
investigation in late July that is soon
thereafter we received requests for
follow-up inquiry and we did the
follow-up and provided that information
in November and that we administrative
it closed the file in January and then
earlier this month we received some
additional information and we passed
that on as well the White House which
has only said that it learned the full
extent of the allegations against Porter
last Tuesday shifted its timeline today
acknowledging the FBI did give
information on Porter to the White House
personnel security office the
House personnel Security office staffed
by career officials received information
last year and what they considered to be
the final background investigation
report in November in the view of
personnel security office
the FBI's July report required
significant additional investigatory
field work before personnel Security
office could begin to evaluate the
information for adjudication the White
House personnel security office located
across Pennsylvania Avenue from the
White House handles the information for
security clearances the press secretary
today said the office had not completed
the data gathering for Porter's security
clearance at the time he resigned as
director ray said information was still
coming to the White House personnel
security office in February and to
public appearances today President Trump
refused to answer shouted questions
about Porter and the issue of domestic
violence
mr. president you of them give a message
to domestic violence victims Democrats
saw an opening and jumped on it I
haven't heard the president say
something directly about how bad
domestic abuse is you know to have a
spokesperson get out and say something
is not good enough avoiding any
on-camera comment about the controversy
president Trump tried to keep the focus
on his agenda meeting with sheriff's on
immigration and opioid abuse huddling
with members of Congress on trade
warning he won't stand by while foreign
steel and aluminum are dumped into the
u.s. my administration is now reviewing
the reports and considering all options
and part of the options would be tariffs
coming in but that talk provoked words
of caution from fellow Republicans I
think we do need to be careful here that
we don't start a reciprocal battle on
tariffs invoking national security
I think it's really hard to make that
case invites retaliation that would be
problematic for and this Congress starts
taking up daca and immigration reform
President Trump gave Democrats a shove
tweeting negotiations on daca have begun
Republicans want to make a deal and
Democrats say they want to make a deal
wouldn't it be great if we could finally
after so many years solve the daca
puzzle this will be our last chance that
will never be another opportunity March
5th
in his congressional meeting the
president tweaked Democrats at the table
including Ohio senator sherrod Brown and
I actually think that we can go
bipartisan on infrastructure maybe even
more so than we can on knock on it
because the difference is we want to
help daca you don't I'm sure you do the
White House continues to insist that it
will not trim down its daca plan to get
approval from Congress saying it still
has to have the president's four
principles trading a path to citizenship
for 1.8 million people for a border wall
and other border security measures and
end to chain migration in an end to the
visa lottery program Brett the White
House hopes that when all the votes are
done in Congress over the next couple of
weeks its plan will be the last one
standing John where are we on the
possibility of the president sitting
down with Bob Muller and what his his
team is saying my sense tells me that
his legal team is leaning firmly against
the idea and here's the reason why
they've been reading an old case about
Mike sb the clinton-era agriculture
secretary from the late 1990s which
found in the case that the president
that those seeking information from the
president in this case an interview must
demonstrate with specificity why it is
likely that the subpoena materials hear
his testimony contain important evidence
and why this evidence or equivalent
evidence is not practically available
from another source his legal team put
out a page about a month ago saying that
they produced tens upon tens of
thousands of documents there have been
interviews that the special counsels
office has conducted with 37 people
either from the White House or the
transition his legal team says that
there is no evidence of any
kind of collusion here so far no
evidence of obstruction because of the
production of these these documents and
that what was happening was it was a
counterintelligence operation and not a
criminal investigation and the president
could not obstruct a counterintelligence
operation because he by virtue of his
position is is involved in all that so
it looks like at this point given the
the preponderance of the evidence that
they're looking at that they they may
not do an interview with Muller but I
don't think that decision is it's fully
been made yet yeah we should point out
that we asked for someone to come out
here talk about a host of issues
including including the Rhea timeline
they didn't send somebody out today not
surprising there were a lot of questions
that briefing there there were and the
problem for the White House has been
that there's an evolving narrative here
now they got blindsided by this last
Tuesday they scramble try to get out
something that would you know hold the
fire line back for a little while then
it started to overwhelm them so they had
to come out again I think the one person
who can really clear all of this up
would be the chief of staff John Kelly
remember Lanny Davis wrote a book some
time ago tell the truth tell it early
tell it yourself and tell it all yeah
and the one person who can do that is
John Kelly knows how long it went down
this week are you I've a new claim that
we may see him alright John thank you as
always